ever since Joe Rogan introduced smelling
salts to his podcast back in 2021
there's been dozens of hilarious
reactions to guest taking the big sniff
these are the top three JRE smelling
salt moments starting off with the whole
protect our Parks
crew no way no
[Music]
way you got too deep you went too deep
you went too
deep bigger nose bigger nose nose up
next is Theo Von we should always have
some on the hand oh got him got him got
him thought it was going to be dead and
it wasn't and at number one is Brian
Simpson saying it can't be that bad it
can't be that bad hold it
[Music]
is oh my God oh my God he went too close
oh my God to take a break